plus loin encore avec vous guident leur
trac c'est notre correspondant en
ukraine bonjour à vous vous êtes rendu
récemment à odessa et vous pouvez
témoigner du blocus russes comment
est-ce que ça se passe concrètement
oui absolument il y à des navires
certains de ces navires sont pleins avec
des dizaines de milliers de tonnes de
maïs ou de blé
et ils sont bloqués sur le port je pense
qu'il est important de souligner que les
ukrainiens n'avoue pas avoir miné sa
littoral il dit que ce sont les russes
qui l'ont minet ils disent que ils ont
mis en place d'autres sortes de défenses
bon leur parole vaut ce que cela vaut
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
ukrainiens ne crois pas absolument pas à
la parole des russes donc tout déblocage
des ports doit être accompagnée d'une
sorte de mission
internationale pour garantir la sécurité
pour empêcher justement comme disait un
bruno que la russie exploitent la
situation pour faire arriver de la
marine russe sur la côte sud de
l'ukraine ce que je peux dire aussi que
j'ai pu constater c'est que les
agriculteurs et le port en ukraine ils
font tout pour essayer d'acheminer leurs
produits par d'autres chemins j'ai vu de
l'huile de tournesol en train d'être
chargés dans des camions sur le port où
je me suis rendu pour être acheminées
ensuite par la route vers la frontière
de l'ukraine avec l'union européenne je
suppose la roumanie mais la capacité
routière et pour les chemins de fer et
plusieurs fois moindre que la capacité
maritimes tout le monde dit que le seul
moyen de vraiment fournir les besoins du
monde en termes de céréales ukrainien
s'est vraiment débloqué ses ports mais
côté ukrainien il n'y a pas de très
grands d'optimisme quant à l'est real il
à la réalité de cette possibilité
l'ukraine accuse la russie de vouloir
exprès empêcher le crâne d'exporter ses
grands parce que cela fait monter les
prix bien sûr pour les exportations
russes cela pourrait provoquer des
crises dont des pays qui dépendent
beaucoup du grain ukrainien est donc
peut-être des vagues migratoires on
entend toutes sortes d'accusations de la
part de toutes sortes officiel
d'ukrainiens comme quoi cette crise est
une crise que la russie a fait a créé
exprès comme une sorte de bénéfice
collatéral si vous voulez de son oeuvre
selon
gilbert je profite de votre présence
pour faire un point sur l'avancée des
combats quelles sont les nouvelles de
lui dont basse
alors il est très difficile de savoir où
en est la situation assez verrou donetsk
à une heure précise parce que la
situation est très dynamique mais les
ukrainiens ne lâche pas le contrôle de
cette ville clé dans la région de
lougansk ils disent ce matin avoir
repoussé une offensive russe sur la
localité de toshiba au sud de
severodonetsk que les russes avaient
pris puis les ukrainiens avaient repris
il ya quelques jours aujourd'hui les
russes apparemment ils ont essayé de
reprendre un nouveau taux steve niles y
sont pas réussi mais clairement la
situation pour les forces ukrainienne à
sévir donetsk est assez difficile les
attaques s'intensifient aussi sur
d'autres directions temps le dôme basse
notamment sur bach mouthe aujourd'hui
une ville dont la région de donetsk où
il y aurait eu une frappe aérienne qui
aurait fait des victimes mais on ne sait
pas encore pour le moment combien
gilbert crack correspondant france 24 en
ukraine merci à vous